so I also down see I think you just  could just not listen until his parents  just say I can I can barely do it  Hey whoo yeah yeah it was too much that  was a tough one  I'm speechless I I don't I've never seen  something so heartbreaking to see you  I kept thinking that he had changers in  mind I just never did Merce felt people  are wondering why you just could not  stand up to your parents this thing is  to move they take mushroom I can say  that that they semi of doom from lord  root neither would that you can say that  mater beloved happy new solutions  Manasquan shaman Yankovic logic nice  underhook joke Laura like do you if you  had to do it all over again would you  tell your parents about the children  before coming to the States  yes  [Music]